[Música]
el congreso peruano le negó la salida
del país al presidente pedro castillo
que planeaba asistir a la posición del
nuevo mandatario colombiano gustavo
petro el legislativo teme que el jefe de
estado pida asilo político en bogotá
para evadir las cinco investigaciones
que la fiscalía adelanta en su contra
estados unidos declaró la viruela del
mono con la emergencia sanitaria
nacional con lo que las autoridades
podrán mejorar la respuesta al brote
cuando se han reportado al menos siete
mil contagios la declaración permite que
las agencias accedan a fondos de
emergencia y facilita la gestión de
vacunas y tratamientos
la justicia rusa condenó a 9 años de
prisión a la campeona mundial de
baloncesto estadounidense brittney
griner por tenencia y tráfico de drogas
por llevar aceite de cannabis al entrar
a moscú el pasado febrero su abogada
indicó que recurrirá la sentencia
el presidente joe biden la calificó de
inaceptable
bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy valentina torre sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
perú el presidente pedro castillo acudió
a la fiscalía para rendir cuentas sobre
su presunta participación en un caso de
tráfico de influencias se trata de una
de las cinco investigaciones abiertas en
su contra
la audiencia se produjo un día después
de que su primer ministro y estrecho
aliado a nivel torres anunciará su
renuncia al gobierno de castilla una
situación que agudiza la inestabilidad
política en ese país andino el informe
es de ariana villacorta
rodeado de sus abogados y policías
antimotines
el presidente peruano pedro castillo
camino de manera sorpresiva desde
palacio de gobierno hasta la fiscalía
para responder un interrogatorio sobre
una denuncia por presunto tráfico de
influencias en el proceso de ascensos en
las fuerzas armadas y policiales una de
las cinco investigaciones en su contra
en declaraciones a la prensa el
mandatario insistió en su inocencia
primero a decir que no soy parte y no
formo ninguna red filipina
eso lo he dicho el día de hoy a la
fiscal de la nación y le he dicho que
voy a demostrar en cualquier espacio
aquí allá y donde sea mi inocencia yo no
cometió a nadie a nadie robado a nadie
ha matado
castillo también se enfrenta a
investigaciones por presunto tráfico de
influencias en la compra de combustible
por parte de la empresa estatal
petroperú corrupción y colusión agravada
en un proyecto de obra pública un caso
conocido como el consorcio puente tarata
plagio en su tesis doctoral y
obstrucción a la justicia en la
destitución de un ministro del interior
a pesar de que el mandatario niega estar
implicado en casos de corrupción en perú
se corren los rumores de que estaría
buscando asilo político por lo que el
congreso le negó permiso para viajar a
colombia para la investidura de gustavo
petro con 67 votos en contra el pleno
del congreso no aprobó el proyecto de
resolución legislativa 27 41 que
autoriza el presidente de la republica
salir del territorio nacional del 6 al 8
de agosto de 2022 castillo es el primer
presidente peruano en ser investigado
por la fiscalía mientras esté en
funciones casi todos los ex presidentes
de las últimas décadas tienen problemas
con la justicia en venezuela las
autoridades condenaron a 17 personas
la fiscalía haber participado en el
supuesto intento de magnicidio contra el
presidente nicolás maduro los hechos
ocurrieron en 2018 cuando dos drones
detonaron mientras el mandatario daba un
discurso en caracas entre los
sentenciados se encuentra juan reque
sense un ex diputado opositor que hizo
parte de la asamblea nacional que estuvo
bajo el control del antichavismo la
condena se produjo por homicidio
intencional contra el presidente y
terrorismo entre otros cargos
en otras noticias el departamento de
salud de eeuu declaró el proyecto de la
viruela del mono como una emergencia
sanitaria nacional esta decisión del
gobierno llega en medio de fuertes
críticas contra la administración del
presidente joe biden por su respuesta al
virus el tema ya tiene incluso tintes
políticos en la unión americana de cara
a los comicios de medio término en
noviembre el informes de juán pupiales
una carrera contra un nuevo brote la
viruela del mono ya es una emergencia
sanitaria pública para el gobierno
federal de eeuu
la medida libera presupuestos de
emergencia permite la reorganización de
personal médico y da más acceso al
ejecutivo central sobre las personas
contagiadas y vacunadas el objetivo
contener el virus antes de que sea
endémico
estamos redoblando los esfuerzos y
asegurándonos que estamos cumpliendo con
el país y con lo que la gente necesita
en hua equipo mit la decisión de la
administración de joe biden de declarar
el brote como una emergencia sanitaria
llega después de que la organización
mundial de la salud emitiera su alerta
global la unión americana ha distribuido
1,1 millones de dosis de la vacuna
contra esta viruela pero hay clínicas en
nueva york o san francisco que solamente
han podido aplicar una de las dos dosis
del antídoto por falta de suministros al
respecto en new york times reportó que
el gobierno estadounidense no solicitó
de manera temprana a la fabricante
bavarian nordic el embotellado de lotes
de vacunas que ya eran de su propiedad y
en medio de esta polémica el gobernador
de florida from distante quien se
muestra como un posible candidato
presidencial republicano cargo contra
las recomendaciones sanitarias del
gobierno contra el virus james sé que
estoy tan cansado de los políticos y
vimos esto con el hobbit intentan
sembrar terror en la población hay gente
que nos está llamando madres que están
preocupadas por si sus hijos se pueden
contagiar en el colegio no vamos a
regresar a folchi en los 80 cuando él le
intentaba decir a las familias que iban
a contraer vih por ver la televisión
juntos y vivir y ver estados demócratas
como nueva york california illinois ya
habían emitido su emergencia sanitaria
la semana pasada alrededor de 7000
estadounidenses han sido infectados con
la viruela del mono la cual presenta
casos actuales en 70 países del mundo el
virus produce fiebre y sarpullidos entre
otros síntomas se contagia
principalmente con el contacto y
presenta una mortalidad de en torno al 1
por ciento el primer ministro de hungría
viktor orbán viajó hasta texas donde
participó en la conferencia de acción
política conservadora y defendió
defendió su política de tolerancia cero
contra la inmigración ilegal el
mandatario húngaro aseguró que pese a
recibir precio de la unión europea y de
otras naciones para flexibilizar sus
medidas continuará aplicando su política
asimismo resaltó que es el único el
líder político anti inmigración de
europa
la justicia rusa con de 99 años de
prisión a la deportista estadounidense
brittney griner por tenencia y tráfico
de drogas desde washington el presidente
joe biden tachó de inaceptable la
sentencia y aseguró que hará todo lo
posible para que la jugadora de
baloncesto campeona mundial y olímpica
vuelva a su país más romeros a la tiene
los detalles
nueve años de prisión es la condena que
ha recibido hoy la estrella del
baloncesto estadounidense brittney
griner por parte de un tribunal ruso
es casi la máxima pena que puede llegar
a sentenciarse por tenencia y tráfico de
drogas en rusia el delito que ahora pesa
sobre sus hombros después de que fuera
detenida en moscú con aceite de cannabis
en la maleta en febrero pasado desde su
casa la asociación nacional de
baloncesto masculina y femenina le
mostraron su apoyo el veredicto y la
sentencia de hoy es injustificado y
desafortunado pero no inesperado y
whitney bréyner sigue detenida
equivocadamente el compromiso de la nba
femenina y masculina con su regreso no
flaquea y es nuestra esperanza estar
cerca del final de este proceso para que
graiver regrese finalmente a eeuu
para que eso suceda la casa blanca
quiere jugar la carta de víctor wood un
ruso encarcelado en eeuu por tráfico de
armas e intercambiarlo por la deportista
y por william un ex infante de marina ha
detenido también en rusia es una jugada
de la que no se sabe mucho todavía
todo el mundo tiene conjeturas sobre
cuál es la propuesta no entraré en
detalles pero es una propuesta seria e
instamos a que la acepten deberían
haberla aceptado hace semanas cuando la
hicimos por primera vez pero mientras
rusia y eeuu juegan su ajedrez político
con los prisioneros la defensa de la
jugadora ha asegurado que apelará la
sentencia para acercar a la libertad de
esta estrella campeona mundial y
olímpica de baloncesto
vamos a nicaragua donde la policía
impidió la salida del palacio episcopal
en matagalpa de lewis por rolando
álvarez seis sacerdotes y seis laicos
que se dirigían a oficiar una misa el
sacerdote transmitido en vivo lo
ocurrido y en las imágenes se observa un
grupo de policías antidisturbios con
bastones y escudos bloqueando el paso de
los religiosos el obispo es uno de los
más fuertes críticos del gobierno del
presidente daniel ortega
se cumplen 60 años desde la muerte de la
icónica actriz estadounidense marilyn
monroe la promesa de la pantalla grande
falleció a los 36 años tras haber
protagonizado más de 30 películas entre
ellas los caballeros las prefieren
rubias' y the seven year itch pese a ser
una de las mujeres más famosas y
queridas del mundo del espectáculo su
vida privada estuvo llena de abusos y
adicciones que la llevaron a una muerte
prematura
así concluimos esta emisión de noticias
a ustedes les agradecemos su sintonía y
les recordamos que pueden ampliar toda
la información en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom
[Música]